the hayate hotel in mogadishu turned
into a battleground on friday night
al-shabab gunmen blasted their way into
the building
with two car bombs before seizing
control of it
somali security forces launched a
counter-offensive witnesses say there
were several explosions followed by
exchanges of gunfire that continued
through the night and into saturday
al-shabab has claimed responsibility
these types of attacks have been a
hallmark of ultraviolet operations a
couple years ago in particular and they
kind of slowed down a little bit but we
see them popping up again
footage from the scene shows extensive
damage to the hotel
several people have been taken to
hospital
the victims reportedly include children
as well as the hotel's owner these
hotels are usually attacked because
that's areas where government officials
congregate
and so there's a lot of meetings a lot
of activity especially right now with
the new government coming into into
place and setting up a lot of its
appointments and its positions but
there's also
often been a secondary element to some
of these you know al-shabab runs a very
extensive extortion racket within
mogadishu itself and they've targeted
business owners that haven't complied as
well
the armed group is affiliated to
al-qaeda and has carried numerous
attacks in mogadishu in the past decade
its aim is to establish a system of
government in somalia based on sharia
law muhammad al jazeera